welcome everyone this is your fantasy
fire drill it is week number three and
i'm matt campbell we're going to get
your lineup set i got you covered don't
worry
your fantasy fire trill back with you
here as we are every sunday at noon
eastern presented
father miller light cantenna now i'll
get plenty of your questions in you've
been feeding them in in the brf and
always continue to do so
but before we get to those questions we
need some information
we need those injury updates and i have
everything for you
for our early games for week number
three so let's get into those injuries
now a lot of big names are
out today and we start with the falcons
and we start with julio jones he will be
out today with the hamstring injury uh
calvin ridley is wide receiver three for
me against the chicago bears
loving cal ridley i got him on a bunch
of teams hopefully you do as well could
be a big week for him
moving on from julio jones let's talk
about the rams backfield because the rib
injury from cam akers will take him out
today
i have daryl henderson a few spots ahead
of malcolm brown
they are both flex plays it would be
nice to see one of these guys take the
reigns of this backfield
but it may not just happen yet they're
both flex options today
against the buffalo bills we move on
from that backfield and go to the
buffalo backfield because rookie zach
moss will not play for the bills today
so it makes it a lot easier to start
devin singletary with confidence
as an rb2 as he takes on the rams today
so move on from the buffalo backfield
now
and we talk about the raiders let's get
to a couple of these injuries here josh
jacobs is in
he is rb10 also in for the raiders
somebody you absolutely want to have
is darren waller he will also play today
for the raiders
these are your superstars for fantasy
but they will not have the rookie henry
rugs henry ruggs will be out today for
the raiders
not interested in any of their other
receivers fire up jacobs
and fire up waller with confidence move
on from the raiders to the team they are
playing today
and that is the new england patriots and
not only will they have nikhil harry as
you see
he is in today and so is julian edelman
now i don't have a lot of interest in
harry in your lineup
uh they do not have james white still of
course but julian edelman
a solid wide receiver too maybe more on
the lower end
but we'll doing be doing the work in ppr
format moving on from the patriots here
and we talk about the eagles jaylen
rager is out gonna miss some time with
the thumb injury
uh zach hurts is my tight end three
goddard's inside my top ten and i am
expecting potentially a 30-touch week
out of mile sanders
taking on a very beatable bengals
defense i don't know if the eagles are
gonna win
but it's gonna be a busy one for mile
sanders got top three potential this
week
for the eagles now the niners we got all
kinds of injuries here you got rahim
mostert you know about that one
we'll have tevin coleman out today so
let's start with the backfield there
jerick mckinnon is my rb24 jeff wilson
jr is my rv 36 so you have a low end rb2
and a flex option there for a team that
you know
wants to run the football and a big part
of that of course no jimmy garoppolo
today and
no george kittle today so no george
kittle
i got jordan reed as tight end 16. the
matchup isn't as good as it was
last week but i don't mind the niners
facing the giants even at less than 100
percent
so we go from the 49ers back over to the
afc
because aj brown is out and he's not
only out today
but according to adam schefter of espn
the bone bruise
has been slow to heal he could miss more
time
i have corey davis in the flex area uh i
would say adam humphries a little lower
than that but if you are not getting
john smith in your lineup each and every
week you are asking to lose two
touchdowns last week
three already on the season he is
ripping it up he is the member of the
titans receiving corps
that will continue to shine in a very
big way moving on from that afc south
team to the houston texans
because duke johnson is out now it's not
anything great here for david johnson
uh he's rb25 for me taking on pittsburgh
maybe a couple more catches coming his
way
but he's a low end rb2 high-end rb3 with
duke johnson
out of the lineup with uh the texans
taking on the pittsburgh steelers today
jameson crowder is out le'veon bell is
out
that tells you you can continue to
ignore the jets they're the worst team
in fantasy
they're the worst team in reality this
is the only guy that would really mean
anything in that passing game
so continue to forget the new york jets
now we are into our late game action
and now let's get into more four o'clock
game news phillip lindsey not expected
to play because of his foot injury
melvin gordon to me uh
rb 21 against tampa i think he'll
continue to be the man i said to you at
the beginning of the season
he could get a stranglehold on this
backfield i think he has it
already now we know courtney sutton's
out for the year jerry judy is up in the
air for this game later on today
i don't really care too much i know
people are asking about kj hamler
they're on their backup quarterback now
with you lockout as well
i think i would just stay away from
denver other than melvin gordon
and of course noah fan a really talented
player who much like johnny smith
is going to continue to get targets with
wide receivers injured on his team
kenny galladay should should be making
his 2020 debut today now
he is said he's not at 100 i wouldn't be
surprised if he was on a snap count
today
i'll tell you this i i throw him in that
low wide receiver two range if he beats
those expectations
call it a win but i think they're being
careful with kenny gallaudet
as you might expect with him missing the
first two weeks of the season moving on
from kenny gallaudet
more wide receiver injuries christian
kirk is out he might be on the end of
your bench i don't know if you really
need to keep him around
right now deandre hopkins is doing
exactly what he did in houston
over 30 percent of the target share he
is the man in an
offense that looks really really good
right now with tyler murray
obviously deandre hopkins so no kirk
even more targets out there
for the cardinals receiving court now
moving on from that injury
we have some other big ones devonte
adams is supposed to well the packers
are playing tonight i don't think he's
going to be out there but the packers
are holding out hope look
if you've got to make a lineup decision
before this game is played
don't risk the zero don't put adams in
your lineup now can you move them to the
flex and
maybe see about lazard or valdez
scantling or anybody else playing
tonight or tomorrow
sure but do not bank on devante add was
being out there
against the saints tonight speaking of
the saints
they already told us this michael thomas
will not play now it looks like he'll be
back for week number four
traequan smith a low end flex option not
as confident about emmanuel sanders
but right now alvin kamara is really
getting a lot of targets as a result of
michael thomas being out of the lineup
so you're obviously playing here with
confidence
and i do think you could play jared cook
with confidence to be a potential
top five tight end he came through with
the touchdown last week against the
raiders now
monday night football i don't think
we're going to see sammy watkins even if
we do
got to get full clearance from the
concussion he did have a full practice
the last practice of the week but he's
got the neck issue
and they're playing the ravens you know
this is this is what sammy watkins does
you never know when it's going to come
through i don't think you even bother
with them so
even if he plays forget about sami
watkins for week number three all right
those are all of the injuries yes it's a
lot of them so now
let me help you out what questions do
you have for me we're gonna check those
out right now let's get your winning
lineup ready to go for week three
should i flex kareem hunt or taran
mclaurin half point ppr
uh i love terry mclaurin this week i
know ward's gonna play for the browns a
little other defensive
injury news but i love terry mclaurin i
think he's got top 12 potential
if you have this kind of question you
have a very good team because not often
am i going to tell you
to bench kareem hunt let's move on from
that with terry mclaurin in your
lineup are you surprised by cam newton's
fantasy resurgent
i'm not shocked big passing game against
seattle on sunday night football last
week
however i do worry about the rushing
touchdowns now
i think it'll continue because right now
he is the running back to own for the
new england patriots i would even
consider
selling high on cam newton if you're set
at your quarterback position
continue uh after cam newton is chris
carson
a sell high candidate with seattle's new
look air raid offense
no he's not because he is the man in
that backfield
and the beautiful bonus of chris carson
which we haven't always gotten
because he's catching the ball as well
so no i'll tell you this right now
general thought i am not trading any
running backs that are getting the job
done this early
look at all the injuries we had last
week hang on to your running back depth
this early on
make those trades later on chris carson
is not a sell high
uh i added devonte freeman and wayne
gallman which one should i start look i
don't really like either one of these
guys
i already admitted by the giants they
couldn't get them the full playbook i
said on waiver wire weekly this past
week
that when you look at this situation it
might take some time
for freeman to become the guy in the
backfield i don't think it happens today
i rank galman a little bit higher i
don't have confidence in any of the
giant running backs in today's match-up
uh should i start mitch strabisky versus
the falcons or deshawn watson against
the steelers look
i think trubisky is a good flex play but
i'm not playing him over deshawn watson
i don't have either guy in the top 10
this week i will tell you that
excuse me trubisky's good streamer play
i would start watson i'm going to play
the talent here
over the matchup don't have a ton of
confidence in either guy
moving on from that who's the most
undervalued fantasy player in the league
i throw jono smith in that conversation
i throw jared cook in that conversation
um
there's a decent amount of guys if
you're thinking that way these are the
kind of guys that you want to hang on to
kareem hunt's probably in that
conversation as well
just solid guys that get it done and
maybe don't get that superstar love a
couple of the names right there
uh is kj hamler a sneaky adding 12 team
these guys are getting ahead of me on
this but
look i i don't think so let's see how
this week goes
um i don't think anybody's rushing to go
get him off the waiver wire
i think this is gonna be melvin gordon's
offense with all of the injuries in the
passing game right now and i also think
by the way
that noah fan is the receiver wide
receiver or tight end to own
for the denver broncos uh who should i
start at half point dpr julian edelman
or keenan allen dustin herbert's still
starting for the chargers that's a good
thing i don't like what happened to rod
taylor
but i like the chargers i've had to make
this move uh i'm gonna go with
allen i think he's a higher upside play
half point ppr hurt settlement a little
bit more
so keenan allen is in your lineup over
julian edelman moving on from that one
josh kelly's staying with the chargers
is averaging 17.5 carries per game
is he a better player this week than
mark ingram i'm okay with that if you
want to go there
i'm okay with it i will say this ingram
against the chiefs
should have more opportunities including
more opportunities to score i think
ingram is a safer
play but josh kelly as i told you a
couple weeks ago
is carving out a very nice roll for the
chargers ingram's safer
kelly a little bit more upside moving on
from a very good question there
should i flex robbie anderson or corey
davis i'll go robby anderson uh
the panthers are not a good football
team so they have to throw
so there are targets there and even more
targets could be there
for robbie anderson with christian
mccaffrey on the ir so robbie anderson
is in your lineup there
king uh moving on from that is joe
burrow cementing himself as a qb1 i
think we're a little early before that i
love joe bernal
love joe burr i'd go to his party and
run anything he wanted me to do at his
party because joe burrow
is a future star in this league the
rushing helps i think he'd get himself
into low-end qb1
status at some point this season i don't
think cemented
is the right word for joe burrow as a qb
one just yet
should i drop daniel jones for justin
herbert
sure i think he'll get a little bit more
running out of her but
they're about the same to me but the
injuries there for the giants obviously
losing saquon
i'm okay with the move and by the way if
it doesn't work out you're not missing
anything with jones you're not missing
anything with herbert you continue to
stream your quarterbacks and you'll be
just fine
uh next one here am i crazy for playing
jared mckinnon over austin eckler and
half point ppr i'm not going to call
anyone crazy
but don't do that do not do that eckler
is firmly entrenched in that role and
look
i think we're all hoping that jerick
mckinnon is the guy but it's not like he
had all these touches last week and jeff
wilson jr is there and jeff wilson jr is
a proven player for the niners so no
do not make that move nice spot to be in
though if you get to bench derek
mckinnon this week
uh what is james robinson ceiling
uh my old friend the miz not too happy
with him that i told him to play terry
mclaren for robinson i could still be
right what's the ceiling the ceiling is
rb2 look he scored a garbage time
touchdown
i don't think the jaguars are as good as
we saw in week number one i don't think
they're as bad as we saw against the
dolphins
on thursday night football i think he's
a fine rb2
and don't forget dj chart didn't play
this week moving on from that
standard league here should i start
tyler higbee or t.j oxen
uh i gotta go higbee and i like both
players this week a lot but i
really really really like what i'm
seeing out of the rams offense right now
plus kenny galladay back probably hurts
hawkinson a little bit i know the
match-up is good
once again a nice spot to be in there i
think higbee especially in the standard
league has more touchdown potential so
that puts it over the top for me
uh would you go with odell or hollywood
brown at wide receiver two i have these
guys basically back to back in fact
i will do a live look at my rankings
just so you can see this
but i do have beckham a couple of spots
higher than hollywood brown
um if you want to go for supreme upside
maybe there's a shootout potential on
monday night you want to play hollywood
i get that i think odell's a little bit
safer though moving on how do you who do
you like more this week mike davis or
david montgomery so this to me
is about your scoring system if you're
in ppr
i'm good going with davis i do think
montgomery is safer i would play
montgomery
uh for the most part because they're
playing the falcons
falcons defense not very good so i lean
more towards montgomery davis does have
some good value though
in ppr uh should i start evan ingram or
dallas goddard i'm on dallas goddard
i've been in dallas scott
since the preseason the eagles have no
receivers also and jeffrey is still out
uh rhaegar is is out as we know it's
zach gertz and dallas goddard it's one a
and one b in that offense other than
miles sanders in terms of those
receivers
those are the guys get dallas scott in
your lineup and keep them there because
he's going to be very busy this season
for the philadelphia eagles
uh are you where are you ranking russell
gage this week you want a live ranking
update i got you
where am i ranking russell gage i put
him on the waiver wire this week russell
gauge to me is a wide receiver three
he's inside my top 35 more value in ppr
he's getting garbage time and of course
no julio today
so he moves up in the world he's got
more targets than julio anyway this
season believe it or not
uh what else does aaron jones need to do
to get the rb1 from respect he deserves
i give him that respect he's got plenty
of respect for me and
probably know devonte adams tonight
which means aaron jones
could very well likely finish as rb no
rb number one this week i'm gonna say it
right now if aaron jones finishes rb
number one
again no one should be surprised i give
that respect to aaron jones
everyone else should be doing the exact
same thing
uh what level of rb could i
realistically get back in the trade for
tyler lockett
these are always kind of general
questions i always shoot high
lock it to me probably get you a top 20.
i would shoot though
for a top 15 running back because he's a
big play guy
in a great offense he can turn the game
around like that
for fantasy for reality so i shoot for a
top 15 running back if you're trying to
trade tower locket but make sure your
wide receivers are really good
because he's a really good player uh
what do you make of the rams running
back roulette i i
talked about this earlier acres being
out clears it up a little bit i think
they trust malcolm brown a little bit
more because the pass pro
however daryl henderson looked like
their best back of the season last week
against eagles
it's a very small sample size i
understand that i think henderson's got
more upside
but we have to read the tea leaves if
brown's getting more snaps
there's probably obviously more
opportunity out there these are flex
plays
until further notice uh added drew
sample and dalton
schultz which is the better desperation
play i'm okay with schultz
i'm okay with that i think they're both
desperation plays no doubt about it but
i'm okay with salt i think there's some
opportunity there
marquez valdez ganttlinger judy for last
wide receiver three and halfway ppr
looks like adams is out once again this
is late game action this is tonight
action i go mvs
uh just because adam's being out of the
lineup i don't trust judy you gotta back
a quarterback there now with driscoll
so get mbs in your lineup in the half
point ppr uh which texans wide receiver
belongs to my lineup will fuller brandon
cooks
if it's anybody that's fuller cook's
coming back this week
it looks like texas are a little shaky
right now but i'm going to say will
fuller
and even bill o'brien said we got to get
that guy the ball more so
hopefully they listen to their coach not
that bill o'brien always makes the best
calls
which running back will feast for the
bucks ronald jones leonard fournette
jones fumbled last week fournette came
in the game jones got back in the game
fournette's gonna be the guy
uh anybody who's a ronald jones believer
a truther
uh just just see what's going on he's
not that good he's never been that good
the opportunity was there he didn't take
that opportunity this is leonard
fournette's backfield leonard fournette
is the running back to own i'm gonna
tell you right now at some point we're
just going to forget about ronald jones
and we've been having these discussions
ty hilton or cd land can't say i'm
pumped about either one of these guys i
will go hilton
because he's further up on his depth
chart for the colts um
i do wonder though is this a different
answer in a couple of weeks
because t.y hilton's got to show it to
us but i still lean here it's only been
two weeks i'm not making crazy changes
just yet
uh if the panthers keep losing should
mccaffrey owners be worried about teams
shutting them down early i
have made this point to multiple people
we're talking about trading for
uh will they shut him down early i think
he'll want to come back but this is when
you start to think about this if they're
out of it if they're a three-win team
come week 14.
are they playing their best player where
they handed a bunch of money to so if
you're thinking fantasy playoffs and all
i'm going to trade for them now
think twice about that for that very
question alone because there's no reason
to put them out there late in the season
if they're out of contention hunter
henry or johnny smith and a half point
ppr
you can't go wrong i'm playing johnny
smith no aj brown by the way if you have
these two tight ends you're doing quite
well and i might want to be selling
hunter henry but i'm playing johnny
smith i'm sticking with him
three touchdowns top receiver for the
titans you keep rolling with johnny
smith uh should i start
antonio gibson raheem hines and ppr oh
hines
how'd that work out for us sorry i think
everybody's saying sorry about nahim
hines
i'll go gibson uh there's touches there
they're coming heinz it seems like it's
jonathan taylor's backfield i gave it to
jonathan taylor as my running back of
the week
i love what he can do i think the colts
are going to stick with him as the guy
so
i think gibson's got more guaranteed
touches i'll go with him this week
never thought i'd be asking this but
zach hurts to jordan ty come on
come on jordan read a nice game last
week that was nice but no
do not overthink this zacharias is my
tight entry this week i also have dallas
goddard over jordan reed as well
do not overthink this it's two weeks in
ernst is fine he's still the top
receiver for the eagles
they don't have wide receivers you're
playing zachary
is deontay johnson the fantasy wide
receiver one in pittsburgh once again
it's been two weeks i don't want to over
hype this
i don't think so but if this turned into
a 1a and 1b
conversation with judo i wouldn't be
surprised but i do think he's in that
comment i think it's a lot closer than
we expected it to be juju is a better
player
let's see how the targets shake out i'm
still putting juju ahead but i'm not
being close-minded the fact that dean
deonte johnson could match him soon
enough
through two weeks what would you say has
been the biggest fantasy surprise
um little trubisky no i don't know if
i'd go that far
biggest fantasy surprise i think is the
awful play of carson wentz for fantasy
and the eagles in general i thought they
would be a better team
uh they have not been so far that's been
a very big disappointment
also you got to throw in the vikings
that was a dark horse super bowl team
last year and kurt cousins
has fallen apart so kirk cousins i've
always said this
when he's bad he is awful and we have
seen awful kirk cousins for the first
two weeks hopefully they can rebound
it would help dalvin cook as well uh
which running back has the higher upside
miles sanders with josh jacobs this week
is miles sanders
against the bengals he's healthier i
think he's going to get a bunch of
touches if he got 30 touches today i
would not be surprised at all i think
that'll get the eagles back on the right
track
so i will tell you mile sanders i love
both of these facts this week
both are top 10 backs with top five
potential uh is it time for me to bench
wins for tannehill i have no problem
doing that whatsoever even without aj
brown
um i think you know what the titans are
i think they've established what they
are
van hill can run a little bit as can
wence the eagles need to get wince on
the move more will they make those
adjustments today
we'll see i think tannehill is the safer
quarterback right now
between the two for fantasy will stefan
diggs maintain his level of production
as the season goes on
if he stays healthy that's always been
the thing with diggs he struggles to
play with any kind of injury
but josh allen is playing high-end
football right now you have diggs and
john brown
who compliment each other well and
they're giving defensive spits
stefan diggs when he's at his best is a
top 10 nfl wide receiver and he's a top
10 fantasy wide receiver we've seen both
of those on display
i do believe he can keep this level of
production up
what a great addition for the buffalo
bills uh got burned by scotty miller
last week
sorry is he still ahold he's hurt i
don't think he needs to really hang on
to him he's a bench play
a bench guy but you got goblin and evans
back we know what the tight end position
is it's a mess gronk's a blocker now
i don't think you need to hang on to
scotty miller if you need a spot for
somebody else
a couple more here is michael gallup uh
the odd man out in dallas from the
fantasy standpoint he might be
i mean i think we know marty cooper and
lam are more talented players
but i can see this shifting on a week to
week basis plus deep against his
characters and he gets his targets as
well
um so far he has been the odd man out
but i think this could be a bit of a
headache all season long because they
almost have
too much talent in dallas and we'll get
one more in here
can you help start a petition to get
brian edwards more targets
uh i want josh jacobs getting targets i
want waller getting targets
i i would love to say that hat could
happen eventually but
i don't think we need to start a
petition just yet i think the raiders
are doing just fine with what they have
uh it's gonna take some time he's more
of a dynasty prospect
than a guy in your lineup for 2020. your
questions
have been answered hopefully i got them
right now
week two a mess for injuries let's hope
it's not as bad
but we know we'll be hitting the waiver
wire come week four
and i got you covered this tuesday
waiver wire weekly rapid fire
of the names you need to grab off the
waiver wire i'll catch you for that on
tuesday thursday to look at and of
course we're right back here each and
every sunday
noon eastern for your fantasy fire drill
keep getting those questions in the vr
app and we'll be back with you of course
i'm matt camp this has been your fantasy
fire drill presented
by the miller light cantana good luck in
week three
[Music]
[Music]
foreign